I have video for you today of a long
time trump brown-nosing sycophant one of
the real sick Fox News Trump defenders
realizing on live television that Trump
is absolutely clueless and has no idea
what he's doing and you can actually see
him become more and more enraged
despite being someone who is almost
exclusively wrong on policy I'm talking
of course of Brian Kilmeade
the one that some people think is the
dumb one on Fox and Friends but it may
not actually be the case and of course
there is a lot of competition for that
role that designation on Fox and Friends
we've been talking about Donald Trump's
recent decision to pull back troops in
northern Syria
to allow Turkey to run a military
operation along with Donald Trump's
threat to destroy and obliterate
Turkey's economy if they do anything
Donald Trump doesn't like combined with
within hours turkey bombing Kurdish
forces in northern Syria we've already
talked about all of that
Brian Kilmeade came up with one of the
reasons why Donald Trump's actions are
concerning which is yes they endanger
the Kurds in northern Syria which
happens to be a concern that a lot of
people share it's Noam Chomsky who
shares that concern it's me it's some
Republicans as well and you can just
tell that Brian Kilmeade is disgusted
with Trump in this video and you can
also tell when you go to the wide shot
or I think it's a wide shot the entire
time when you see Steve deucey deucey I
always have to be careful to pronounce
it correctly when you see co-hosts Steve
Doocy and I believe it's Ainsley
Earhardt
they don't want anything to do with this
they are still fully on the sucking up
to trump train and what's funny is that
brian kilmeade if you watch him deliver
any political opinion he always has like
a slightly confused expression on his
face
even if he's making a roundabout point
that has some element of truth which he
does in this case he always seems like
one microsecond away from completely
losing the thread and becoming totally
in Kinnear in
hiren and meanwhile Steve Doocy looks
visibly uncomfortable with what kill me
to saying Ainsley Earhardt seems to want
no part in the conversation one way or
another take a look at this this what a
disaster I mean the president's
statement through Stephanie Grisham is
you know we defeated the the caliphate
the hell face destroyed we would not
have done that without the Kurds who did
all of our fighting while our guys the
reason why our casualties were so low is
because Kurds did all the fighting now
we're saying okay Turks go wipe them out
or force them out what kind of message
is that to the next ally that wants to
side with us meanwhile we're taking
Sunni prisoners and giving them to Sunni
Turkey who's been nothing but
irresponsible though technically a NATO
ally a disaster a series of events I
hope the president will rethink this I
think the president's doing exactly what
he's wants to because he has made from
the get-go very clear to release Isis
fighters campaign promise to end and no
man Steve Doocy as a guy to play off of
his just tough right I mean he sounds
like a little kid he's a 62 year old man
but he sounds like a kid well I think
Trump is just doing what he wants to so
yeah and then that riles up kilmeade
even more as we continue
that's a campaign promise and in the
people that got the Caliphate destroyed
I think when people find out that
somebody else is willing to take over
the fight against Isis they're gonna be
okay with taking it well
Turkey to fight Isis we have given
Turkey permission to do that and to take
and the quote was Turkey will now be
responsible for all Isis fighters their
Kilda and wipe out the Kurds are you
kidding me again we're banning our most
loyal allies who did all our fighters
all we did is arm them and they did all
the work and now we say good luck good
luck surviving well it looks like that's
the attack the White House and the
president's gonna take we're gonna have
as bad as Brian Kilmeade political
analysis is even though he hits on
something here of course Steve Ducey's
dumb comments are just too much but what
good luck surviving Brian that's the
tactic the White House is taking so
there there are these tiny little sort
of hairline cracks that are forming in
the echo
chamber of foxnews by mere coincidence
because Kilmeade wants soldiers in Syria
do you think that after a segment like
this when they go to commercial or after
they're done filming do you think they
go to the break room stand around the
water cooler and they say Brian what was
that all about that was weird what was
what what went on there and what you
have is okay Brian Kilmeade like a clock
that doesn't move it ends up being right
twice a day and Brian Kilmeade has
stumbled upon what is at least a
partially correct take and it just seems
completely out of place on Fox News now
that that's over Fox News can resume the
self eating by the way which is actually
the bigger media story that I think we
should be talking about I've been
preparing you for this for about a year
now I think it's been about a year it's
certainly dating back to last May if not
earlier when we start looking at the
possible separation of Trump and Fox of
Trump and Republicans you have to
understand that there is much more to it
than simply will Fox support Trump in
the 2020 reelection campaign we are
starting to see political disagreements
that are becoming more than just public
they are starting to actually affect the
way that politics is happening behind
the scenes in Washington DC you're
starting to see Moscow Mitch separate
from Trump a little bit more than he has
in the past over this Syria issue you're
starting to see loony Lindsey Looney
Lindsey Graham start to distance himself
from Trump a little bit even though he
was like the greatest Trump brown-noser
out there for a very long period of time
but it's not just forward progress
because then Trump will backpedal and
he'll pull some people back in but then
it'll happen again and we'll see what
ultimately happens I don't know if you
said to me today David take a position
by November of 2020 will Trump and Fox
still have this marriage made not in
heaven but you know with a prenup and
under duress which is I guess the way
most of Donald Trump's relationships
seem to develop will we still have that
in November of 22
or will we have seen a total separation
between Trump and Fox News and if so
that raises a whole host of additional
questions will Trump have moved over to
oen one America News Network which I've
been predicting for a while and Trump is
started to promote a little bit around
the edges will we see those right-wing
media outlets that abandoned Trump
actively promote an alternative will
they promote a Democrat I don't think so
will they promote a primary challenge to
trump or voting third party I don't know
but these are some of the interesting
questions that I look forward to seeing
answered as the campaign continues to
develop let me know what you think will
ultimately happen let me know what you
make by the way of Brian Kilmeade
staking out this position which again
it's not unique to kill me there are
lots of Republicans who want troops in
Syria for different reasons the Kurd the
danger to the Kurds specifically though
is not always the one that you hear